when we begin this NewsHour with
breaking news from Italy former prime
minister Silvio Berlusconi has died at
the age of 86. balusconi had served
multiple terms as leader and was a
powerful figure both in Italian politics
and media he was admitted to a hospital
in Milan on Friday for what AIDS said
were pre-planned tests related to his
leukemia the controversial businessman
created Italy's largest media company
and also briefly owned the leading
football club AC Milan belusconi faced
multiple legal and sex scandals
eventually leading to his resignation
sarakira takes a look back at his life
and his career
[Applause]
was never happier than when performing
in front of his supporters at home or on
the global stage
his playful touch was loved by some
loathed by others whose prime minister
four times and was Italy's
longest-serving post-war leader
this one-time cruise ship crooner turned
property Tycoon went on to own Italy's
biggest media Empire and be chairman of
his beloved football team AC Milan he
wielded tremendous influence with an
estimated Fortune of 9 billion dollars
Berlusconi persuaded many Italians he
was the right man to lead them Bart's
controversy followed him in sobriety he
sometimes seemed to relish
I am the most legally persecuted Man Of
All Times in the whole history of
mankind worldwide because I have been
subjected to more than 2 500 Court
hearings
charm works sometimes even when he kept
in kept in friends waiting but his
attempts at humor often backfired I have
to bring you some greetings greetings
from a man what's his name just a minute
it was someone with a tan Barack Obama
then there was the personal vanity the
face lifts the permanent tan all the
better for selling Italy's image abroad
or so he claimed he rolled with the
political punches as well as the literal
ones
assaulted during a campaign rally in
Milan as a Litany of legal battles
against him became more lurid Italian
patients wore thin he was convicted of
tax fraud in 2013 and later of political
corruption narrowly avoiding jail but
the convictions barred him from office
until 2019 and then there was the
accusations of organizing sex parties
attended by underage prostitutes his
political and personal dramas inspired a
Blockbuster movie
it was the collapsing economy that would
eventually seal his political fate
Italy's burden of debt took it to the
brink of bankruptcy and Berlusconi into
confrontation with European partners
in recent years he faded from Frontline
politics dogged by health concerns he
recasts himself as a nature lover and a
family man bharti became a senator in
2022 and as leader of Forza Italia the
political party that he founded he was
never too far from the Reigns of power
joins us now from Sardinia in Italy he's
not been well for some time right
yeah he has been actually not well ever
since he got covered a few years ago and
he actually said at the time that that
was the worst experience of his life he
never really fully recovered from that
couple to the this form of leukemia that
he had
um that things were quite difficult for
him he had spent already six weeks in
hospital in Milan the same hospital
where he died earlier this year he came
in they officially said it was for
routine checkups the the hospital had
said earlier uh this morning that it was
a quiet night and then uh things went
very fast his close family was called in
his daughter was seen arriving then his
brother and his wife were seen arriving
and then the hospital eventually issued
a statement saying that he had died
his party is still in power but it's now
been relegated to being part of a
coalition how much influence did he
wheeled there towards the end
I think he really did influence all the
way towards the end he did give his
opinion uh during the Electoral the
election campaign uh his party as you
said is part of the ruling Coalition and
has really his ideas have a huge impact
on the political class in Italy at the
moment but he is a man who was very
divisive at the same time so you do have
those who will continue saying that he
was the best thing that happened to
Italian politics since the second world
war certainly he was the longest serving
prime minister uh in recent uh history
but there are those who also say that he
has actually embarrassed Italy with all
his sex scandals his corruption scandals
and also his very flamboyant way of
talking sometimes saying very uh
shocking statements he had also
friendships that were quite questionable
uh either locally here in Italy or for
example he was a big friend of Vladimir
Putin you would see both men here in
Sardinia yachting together and until the
very end he refused to take a stand
against Russia in this war with Ukraine
so certainly a man who had very strong
ideas very decisive ideas had a huge
impact in Italy whether it's politically
or indeed he completely changed the
media landscape when he created his
group media set indeed there speaking to
us from Sardinia and Italy thank you
very much Hara well let's now bring in
Alan Friedman he is a political
commentator and also author of the
biography Berlusconi the Epic story of
the billionaire who took over Italy he
joins us now from Lugano in Italy Alan
you've spent a huge amount of time with
balusconi can you perhaps share one or
two of your more memorable moments with
the man with us
yeah I used to go and see him after
community service every Saturday when I
was making my film uh and he was doing
community service for having been
convicted for tax fraud he told a lot of
stories
um I remember at one point in his vast
luxurious Villa he showed me his photo
gallery uh with pictures of Superman
himself a Superman then he said would
you like to see the famous bunga bunga
room which is the room where supposedly
according to the criminal trials he
faced he had brought underage
prostitutes to have sex with but it
wasn't the bunga bunga room it was just
his dining room and he used to joke like
that
um he was a charming and charismatic
person but very controversial as your
own correspondent from Sardinia just
noted at the end he was a
pro-putin uh friend he was a
controversial figure he had survived 65
70 different uh criminal corruption
cases and his power was diminished at
the end as Georgia Maloney of the right
suppressed his liberal center-right
vision and took over and he became just
a crutch for the new government
and you've described him as the original
populist do you think his flaws were
part of his appeal
I think we have to understand there are
three parts to the berlitz county story
as populist part one is a young Real
Estate Mogul and media Tycoon who uh
lives in the bad old Italy and of
corrupt old ways and gets things done
and becomes a self-made Man part two he
uses his Media power and the purchase of
a football team of Milan ACI Milan to
launch a populist message Fort sitaria
go weekly just like a football slogan
and yes long before Trump Sylvia
Berlusconi was the original populist but
then like many populists he didn't
actually get much done he just served
for a long time mainly was occupied with
preventing himself from facing legal
Jeopardy and did not do the economic and
key reforms that Italy has failed to do
for the last 30 years so a flawed figure
because yes a successful businessman yes
a dominant politician but a man who is
controversial and not loved by many many
Italians today sort of a parabola kind
of a trajectory that went up and came
down that's his life story Alan as you
say he wasn't just a politician but this
media Mogul uh property Tycoon he was
Italy's richest man at times in his
career after very modest Beginnings I
understand I wonder how he thought of
himself in terms of self-reflection and
his success did he share that with you
he did I remember having dinner with
Silvio Berlusconi and Sardinia at his
Villa and he looked around at his
girlfriend at the time and and other
guests famous singers that he liked to
hang out with and he said I'm a rock
star and everybody applauded his own
family and Tony reynus and other singers
applauded and he said I'm a rock star
and he saw himself and the thing was
interesting with with Berlusconi I asked
him do you see yourself as similar to
Donald Trump
and he said no I don't I don't think so
no no no because he he looked down on
Trump whereas Trump when I asked him do
you see herself as Berlusconi Trump said
yeah yeah kind of we're both Rich yeah
a very very interesting thoughts that
Alan Friedman one of balusconi's
biographers um who who wrote the book
balusconi The Epic story official
authorized biography I am the only
official authorized biographer indeed
where Berlusconi agreed he didn't like
the result of my work he said I was too
harsh on him because I put a chapter in
about the mafia and he didn't like that
but he did say that he trusted you well
Alan Friedman there thank you very much
for joining us here on altazira thank
you for your time today
thank you